being a Muslim, like everything felt so
fake. Everything's just so fake. Even
even with what's going on in in
Palestine, it's just
unbelievable. Look at all the Arab
Muslim countries. They sit back and they
just watch. If they really were about
the faith,
they wouldn't [clears throat] just sit
back and and just let the slaughter
happen.
You got it.
>> [snorts]
>> Exactly. They don't care about other
Muslims. Exactly. They don't. So,
I
I mean, I just
I haven't been back there, to be honest,
in a in a long time. My my whole family
is is basically living in the West Bank.
It's like I I can't because if I go back
there, I I wouldn't be okay with seeing
what's going on and do nothing about it.
Yeah.
God has you here for a reason. So,
Islam, you're
>> [clears throat]
>> disenchanted with it. You don't
You see what it is, but
what's
the draw to Christianity? Why did you
choose
Christianity, Christ?
His
Christ's words hit me in a different way
than
than Islam did. Like,
just the teachings, the way Christ
lived,
completely opposite of [snorts]
you know who.
And I don't want to follow that filth
anymore, and
it does nothing for me. It it doesn't
hit a note in my heart.
And
what will be the outcome if when your
family finds out you gave your life to
Christ?
>> I'm
Uh so, I'm a grown man, obviously, and
I'm not doing it for anyone other than
God. Yes. So, it it doesn't matter what
they think. I did I didn't mention it to
my brother. My brother
uh you know, we're we're Americanized,
so it's not like, "Oh, you know, we're
you know, get out of get out of my
house" type stuff, but like You know, he
told
>> murder?
I won't be murdered, no.
And [snorts] I and my my mother
I lost my mother the same year you lost
yours. Oh, I'm sorry.
>> And Wow. 2014 was a Yeah, hard year. I I
you know,
and I
it hurts to this day. And one thing that
also
um
that I'd like to bring up,
Sure. I don't know if you've watched The
Chosen.
I've only seen few shows here and there.
>> So, so there is a scene that hit me
really hard in that scene in that show
where John the Baptist
uh right before he gets his head chopped
off, and he looks out the window, and he
sees the lamb in the field.
That same scene,
I saw my mother
after she passed away, was the exact
same scenario. Like, same field, same
window, everything. When I saw after my
mom passed away, and I'm like, man, this
this
if if that's not talking to me, I don't
know I don't know what to say.
The lamb who saves, [clears throat]
yeah.
That's that's amazing. What month did
your mom pass away in 2014?
Uh April 1st.
Also, mine was March
12th. Well, not too far.
April Fools also. Sorry, New Year.
So, you lost her. What about your
father?
Um my father's actually coming to visit
me this weekend.
Mm, interesting.
>> And I I
I I I
I I don't have a problem telling him. I
actually planned on telling him because
like
I have a relationship with my father,
but
it's not something I'm scared of my
father, you know? I know. I know. You're
a grown man. Maybe you can [snorts]
witness to him. But you say visit.
Does he [clears throat] live in America?
Uh no, he primarily lives overseas in
the West Bank. He just comes back here
to do his doctor visits and and checkups
and stuff like that. He can travel?
Yeah, he he's got an American
citizenship. Um That's why. Yeah, he
doesn't have a uh
Palestinian citizenship or Israeli uh
papers. So, yeah, that's why he's got to
leave and come back. I see. All right.
Yeah. Maybe God will have you plant
seeds. So,
you are
of your own volition, you decided you
want to give your life to Christ. How
long has this conviction been in your
heart?
It's been brewing for a while.
Um I just like I said, the last uh
month, but the last mainly the last
couple days have been really really hit
hard. I
>> [snorts]
>> I actually like
just last night I like
cried myself to sleep because of things
that I was going through, and I just
needed Jesus.
I I need I need Jesus. There's no
there's no other option. Exactly.
He's the only hope [clears throat]
of salvation.
So, that means you're ready to make
[clears throat] the confession. Now, the
journey will be
you got to be intentional
of getting to church, like I told you
what to look for.
God sees your heart.
I know you want to rush to get baptized,
but you're going to have to follow the
process.
And God sees your heart.
So, let's say God forbid you were to die
tomorrow without getting baptized,
that's not going to be counted against
you.
So, that you don't have to fear
because the Lord sees your heart, and
there's something called baptism of
desire.
You wanted to
you ached to get baptized, but you
weren't able to.
So, God is not the kind of God that
says, "Oh, you didn't get baptized,
you're going to hell."
So, do what I told you.
Go find that church I told you to find.
Submit to their authority. Learn. Be
patient.
You'll get
confirmed, baptized.
And that baptism,
when you do it, will unite you to
Christ. But let's say God forbid you die
tomorrow.
You're on your way there, God will
credit it to you. So, you have nothing
to fear.
But you wanted
to acknowledge and confess because you
reached out to me. I don't even
know if you've ever been on my stream,
but you said you've watched me, but you
haven't been on my stream, right? Like
No, I've never I've never been on the
stream, no.
Yeah, so you just found me. Now, that
channel you found me on
was started by some Christians with my
name.
So, I had [clears throat] to take it
over just in case
they're putting stuff
on that
Facebook page
that I didn't approve of. So, I stepped
in. So, thank God you found me there.
So,
you asked
if
you wanted to confess,
and you wanted to join me live. So, I
just want people to know he reached out
to me. I didn't know who he was.
And usually when people reach out to me,
I'll give them the cold shoulder.
I won't just right away because there's
a lot of trolls and fakes.
So, he wants to confess publicly
and acknowledge his faith publicly. So,
you know what confession is, right?
Yeah.
That you're going to now No one sees
your face.
They hear your voice, that's fine.
And you're acknowledging before
multitudes are going to watch this.
You're going to be renouncing Muhammad,
confessing Jesus as Lord.
Yes.
>> that, right?
And you're okay with that.
100%. All right. I just want everyone to
know
no one is paying him. No one's putting a
gun to his head.
Right? I just want this to be clear.
He's [snorts] doing it cuz he's coming
under heavy conviction.
Didn't even know this guy was listening
to me. He reached out to me on Facebook.
So,
you were born in a Muslim home.
You took Shahada.
Right?
>> Yeah.
Well, yeah.
Meaning yeah, obviously they whispered
in your ear. Yeah, yeah. But then later
on, obviously, you had to make Islam
your own.
Like, your own faith.
Right.
Now,
you know Muhammad is a false prophet.
All of the Quran is not the true God.
That you know.
You're aware of this. Yes. But you also
>> that's
Go ahead. No, I was going to say that's
what a lot of Muslims need to do in in
wake up because
it's I feel like it's a it's a numbers
thing at this point. It's it's
you know, they looks like they're just
gathering numbers, numbers, but no one
really believes what they believe.
They're just saying they're Muslim.
Yeah.
Yeah, a lot of people are just Muslims
culturally.
And when they study Islam truly,
understand Islam, they [clears throat]
get repulsed. When they truly study the
Sira of Muhammad,
many of them will get repulsed. Others
will follow that demonic spirit and
become demonized, and they're the
terrorists.
But thank God, most Muslims don't study
their religion.
Now, we hope they come
>> [clears throat]
>> to faith. Now,
the way
to begin your journey, cuz baptism is
part of it.
But you're going to have to go to
church. Tell them, "I've renounced
Islam.
I don't believe Muhammad. I believe
Jesus is Lord.
I need to get baptized. I need to now be
faithful to the church."
But you know who Jesus is, right? He's
not just man.
He's the God man.
Yes.
And you know he's not the Father. He's
not the Spirit, but together they're the
one God cuz they have the same nature.
Correct.
And you also know that what you're
believing is
he died on the cross for your sins,
but he didn't remain dead. He was raised
physically and bodily, right?
Right, after 3 days. Yep, physically.
That body
that was flesh from Mary, he raised and
now it's made immortal, it cannot die.
Right. Now in the flesh. In heaven in
the flesh. You know this, right?
Yes.
And he will return in that physical body
of flesh to judge the living and the
dead.
Yes. Okay.
Well, and you believe this. So, you're
making a confession of belief. So, then
you have to renounce. So, if you want me
to tell you how to renounce, I can't.
The cat's wanting to go out again. This
cat's evil.
So, renounce Muhammad and confess
Christ. So, it's up to you. I can tell
you how to do it
and you can repeat after me.
>> yeah, I can repeat after after you. It's
All right. Well, let's begin and then
you know what you do next. Get to the
church and then you can even show them
this video as proof.
So, they'll think, well, say, "Here,
watch. Here's me
um renouncing Islam."
So, [clears throat] you're going to say
"I renounce that Allah is God."
I renounce that Allah is God.
"I renounce that Muhammad is a prophet."
I renounce that Muhammad is a prophet.
"I acknowledge Muhammad is the
Antichrist."
I acknowledge that Muhammad is the
Antichrist. "A false prophet
A false prophet used by Satan."
Used by Satan. All right.
Now, you've confessed that. Just like
[clears throat] at one time you had to
confess
that he's a prophet. Good. Now,
as I brought this on the screen, I'm
going to enlarge it.
That [clears throat] if you confess with
your mouth
"Jesus is Lord
believe in your heart that God raised
him from the dead, you'll be saved."
For with the heart a person believes
leading to righteousness.
With the mouth he confesses leading to
salvation. So, here it is.
Do you believe in your heart
meaning
you know in your mind and heart
Christ has been raised physically?
I believe with all my heart, yes. All
right.
Then that means you believe he's alive
and he can never die
and that because he's alive
he calls you now to give your life to
him and acknowledge him to be
Lord. Lord in the sense that he's
Jehovah, Lord in the sense that he owns
your life and you'll seek to obey him.
So, you know that, right?
Yes, I do. All right. So, now you're
going to repeat after me.
Ready?
Ready.
"I confess from my whole heart
I confess from my whole heart
you, Jesus
You, Jesus
are Lord
son of God
and I confess
that you are my Lord and my God."
That you are my Lord and my God.
"And I give my life to you."
And I give my life to you.
"So, I ask you, son of God
So, I ask you, son of God
please forgive me."
Please forgive me.
"Wash me of my sins
Wash me of my sins
by your precious blood that you shed."
I'm sorry, what was that?
"By your precious blood that you shed."
By your precious blood that you shed.
"I know in your love for me
I know in your love for me you died for
me."
You died for me.
"So that I could live." So that I may
live. That I can live.
"And I give you my life."
And I give you my life.
"Thank you, Lord."
Thank you, Lord.
"For saving me."
For saving me.
"And I love you, Lord."
I love you, Lord.
"Please never let me go."
Please never let me go.
"It's in your name, Lord Jesus."
It's in your name, Lord Jesus. "I ask
these things."
I ask these things.
"Amen."
Amen.
He heard you. You're his.
Hallelujah.
Hallelujah. Thank you.
No, don't thank me, brother. Um believe
me, if you get to know me, you're going
to see
I'm very filthy and wicked without Jesus
and I deserve hell if he lets me go. But
now what you're going to do,
no one needs to know. This is not some
public. You go to the church
that I told you to look for
get baptized. You're safe. He's with you
now.
He's with you.
He'll never leave you nor forsake you.
So, let me give you some of his
promises, all right? Here you go.
You ready?
I'm ready.
All right.
I'm going to le- leave you with some of
his promises
so you know
that he cannot lie
and he's faithful to keep his word.
Matthew 11:28-30.
"Come to me,
all you [clears throat] who are weary
and heavy laden."
So, you said you're at the breaking
point, you were tired.
He says, "Come to me."
That's when you're ready for me.
"And I will give you rest.
Take my yoke upon you.
Learn from me." Now, yoke
is what they put on
cattle.
If you ever go to a farm you're going to
see two cattle they have a yoke
connecting them so they can work
together, right?
Right.
So, the imagery is
"Come underneath my yoke."
Here's my yoke. Usually a yoke will have
two openings so you can put on the neck
of one ca- cattle and the other.
So, Jesus is under one of them. He's
saying, "Come under
the next one so that together you and I
will carry this yoke together."
"Yoke yourself with me.
Join yourself with me
and learn from me.
Why?
For I am gentle
and humble in heart." See, Jesus never
embarrasses, humiliates anyone. We do
cuz we're sick.
"You will find rest for your souls.
For my yoke is easy and my burden is
light."
I'm going to give you the imagery in a
minute what it means.
Now, here's the promise.
Hebrews 13:5-6.
"Make sure that your way of life is free
from the love of money.
Being content with what you have." Be
content.
Don't live for
passions and pleasures and
bank accounts cuz you're going to lose
all that. And you see you've already
lost a lot.
"For he himself has said,
I [clears throat] will never desert you
nor will I ever forsake you." So, he has
sworn
he'll never abandon you. No matter how
hard it gets.
So, this is your response. So, we say
confidently
so that we confidently say
"The Lord is my helper. I will not be
afraid.
>> [clears throat]
>> What will man do to me?"
He is your Lord.
He's your savior.
He'll not abandon you. Jesus loves you.
Fear nothing.
"What will I be afraid of?
What will man do to me when he's with
me?"
These are his promises. So, the imagery
I'm going to leave you with the yoke.
Okay?
All right.
>> [clears throat]
>> Jesus yoke together. Okay.
The imagery I'm going to leave you with.
Here it is. Let's look at the good
imagery.
Do you see it?
Yeah.
That's a yoke.
That's the yoke.
So, what he's saying is
"Come.
There's a slot for you.
Join yourself to me. We're going to
carry this together."
The We're the carrying means you're
going to have to live in obedience to
him. And it's hard but he'll help you do
it.
So, when you're weak, he'll then pick
you up
and carry you with the yoke that's on
you and him.
He won't abandon you.
That's the imagery.
So, you've now yoked yourself with him.
And he will never leave you.
Remain under his yoke.
Stay under his yoke.
Do not dare
loose yourself from the yoke and walk
away
cuz as long as you're under his yoke,
you're in the safest place possible.
You'll be in his arms.
You get it?
I do.
That's it, brother.
Now, begin your journey, brother. And
you know where to reach me
if you have any more questions, but go
and begin the process of baptism.
Thank you.
God bless you, Tariq. We'll be praying
for you.
God bless you. Thank you.